j'aurais préféré être président il ya
dix ans une période dorée où tout
pouvait être envisagé une phrase
prononcée par michel logis le président
de la communauté d'agglomération de 50
en moyenne à l'occasion des voeux
car l'heure est aux économies
aujourd'hui par exemple entre l'année
2014 et 2015
vous ne trouvez 6 millions d'économies
oui bien que les dotations qui fondent
comme neige au soleil pèse énormément
sur notre budget c'est pas que le cas de
koné tableau c'est tous ces cas dans
toutes les communes
c'est pour ça que j'ai aussi parlé du
pacte financier qui maintient cabab de
certaines garanties financières entre la
communauté d'agglomération et les
communes mais c'est vrai que le maître
mot aujourd'hui faut trouver il faut
faire des économies on n'a plus les
moyens que nous avions avant des
d'agglomération il ya déjà du changement
il ya déjà une autre gestion
il ya déjà d'autres organisations de
strativa aussi et il ya déjà des
directives très précises qui sont donnés
trois audits sont en cours les résultats
seront connus d'ici la fin avril
il ya des certainement des d ahmad
mutualisation à faire à certains
endroits il ya certainement des
améliorations dans la période où de
toute façon ça a été dit c'est dit par
tout le monde
les ressources sont pour les
collectivités territoriales en baisse
mais en même temps pour nous il ya des
aussi des secteurs qui sont extrêmement
important essentiel
ce serait une erreur par exemple de
toucher sur le secteur culturel sur le
secteur associatif qui est aujourd'hui
crée du lien social créé du vivre
ensemble et qui créent de l'emploi
outre ces économies à réaliser des
rendez vous d'envergure attendre
l'agglomération des rendez vous sportifs
comme les championnats du monde de
cyclisme en février prochain et d'autres
plus politiques comme la refonte du
périmètre de l'agglomération qui
évoluera au 1er janvier 2016
michel laugier de rappeler sa vision du
grand saint quentin accueillant demain
les communes de plaisir les clés
villepreux maurepas et coignières tout
en renforçant ses liens avec le plateau
de saclay
je n'ai qu'une seule ambition qu'un seul
objectif faire de saint quentin en
yvelines à des symboles de l'excellence
à la française a conclu le président de
l'agglomération